[Música]
[Aplausos]
hoje eu estou aqui para mudar a idéia é
que você tem da justiça brasileira
eu sou promotora de justiça há 24 anos e
há duas décadas
há mais de duas décadas atrás chegava eu
uma jovem determinada cheia de garra
coragem e idealista que havia sim
passado vários dias de sua vida de sua
juventude porque não de sua adolescência
tentando entender o qual era o papel e o
sentido de um promotor de justiça na
vida da sociedade não tão somente como
um aplicador de leis muito bem
vou contar a história do meu primeiro
dia de trabalho
chego na comarca de ronda alta que
pertinho e repito a quase a mais de duas
décadas e cheia de vontade de atender e
vem o senhor para o meu primeiro
atendimento o senhor de aproximadamente
70 anos para fazer um termo de bem de
ver o termo de bem de ver para quem não
sabe é um era um termo porque acredito
que não se use mais hoje uma espécie de
justiça natural onde o promotor de
justiça com a sua máquina de
datilografia antiga ainda eu já havia
comprado a minha elétrica mas não sabia
escrever ela ainda reduziria e mesmo a
vontade daquele senhor que se já tinha
dito o objetivo do seu atendimento que
era a reconciliação com a sua esposa com
uma de suas esposas uma vez que ele
havia três muito bem chegando na sala da
promotoria
e se depara comigo que era junto ao
fórum na época e me pergunta onde está o
promotor de justiça é muito leve passeio
da feliz meu primeiro dia
sou eu por favor sem ser já pronto para
oferecer o chimarrão
qual a minha surpresa quando o senhor me
disse eu não quero ser atendido por uma
estagiária uma secretário eu exigi o
promotor de justiça
meu mundo riu com certeza e o que penso
eu que ele pensava da imagem da justiça
como será que ele via a imagem de uma
promotora de justiça será que é assim
acho que sim devia ser isso e com o
passar dos anos aquele atendimento
infelizmente nenhum ofereci meu
chimarrão porque iria com certeza me
arrepender até hoje mas com o passar dos
anos eu tive a exata noção que é isso
que as pessoas pensam da justiça
brasileira
em regra uma justiça velha arcaica
ultrapassada e que necessita da ruptura
da quebra de alguns paradigmas para
realmente atingir o fim a que se destina
sim muitos pensam que a justiça é uma
fórmula matemática sem humanidade
principalmente e que a aplicação dela
sem humanidade na perspectiva humanista
e que há a resolução dos conflitos está
na simples fórmula problema mais lei
mais solução talvez se assim pensássemos
e existem leis muito inteligentes não
guarde esta de primeiro mundo inclusive
aqui o trabalho com a qual é o mais
trabalho esses 24 anos de profissão que
é o estatuto da criança e do adolescente
um conteúdo extremamente
é vanguardista humanizado com
instrumentos legais e de garantia de
direitos
mann existe alguma coisa nesse processo
que não explicou porque hoje existem
mais de 6 milhões e 500 mil crianças
para adoção nas casas de acolhimento
institucional do brasil por exemplo e
uma enorme fila de casais e pessoas
pretendentes à adoção esperando por um
bebê não explica porque no ano de 2016
dobrou o problema da do ato infracional
no brasil dobrou o número de
adolescentes infratores 189 mil quando
em 2015 eram 96
mais do que isso caso de estupro entre a
familiar de meninas como nós temos todos
os dias chegando aos conselhos tutelares
a promotoria de justiça
são mais de 175 mil casos novos a cada
ano e isso dados estatísticas oficiais
do conselho nacional de justiça
então temos uma lei e sim uma lei que
abominavelmente se não bem aplicada se
transformará e transformará naquilo que
eu chamo de justiça robocop à justiça
que tem o problema que tem talvez a
solução que seria lei mas sem qualquer
humanidade na sua aplicação e essas leis
que existem e que eu chamo de leis mais
humanas se não são aplicadas como
deveriam
elas devem trazer consigo algo muito
misterioso
e por isso acredito eu que nós tenhamos
que mudar a perspectiva de aplicação
dessas leis para que a justiça seja
realmente humanizado sim pra isso eu
penso em três estratégias e aqui trago
de aplicação da justiça de uma forma
mais eficiente de uma forma que atinja
aquilo que ela veio buscar que é o ser
humano a resolução dos seus conflitos
que foram trazidos à apreciação judicial
ou mais do que isso que eles possam
esses conflitos serem resolvidos muito
antes de levados à justiça
a relação horizontal esta sim já é velha
arcaica ultrapassou de longe
aquilo que nós queremos e daquilo que
nós buscamos para a efetivação da
justiça
nós temos que construir com as
comunidades as redes de apoio social às
instituições soluções conjuntas para
problemas que são postos e são colocados
todos os dias para que nós não perdemos
mais crianças abusadas para que não
tenhamos mais crianças em abrigos para
que não sejamos nós meros aplicadores da
lei ea construção dessas soluções
conjuntas
elas vão muito mais além do que a
fórmula robocop
ela está num acreditado que como disse
chaplin mais do que máquina precisamos
de uma unidade seja na aplicação da lei
seja no nosso dia a dia
isso tem dado em números os resultados
na promotoria de justiça regional da
educação da qual hoje sou titular pe
hoje conta com 30 com marcas
distribuídas entre em 145 municípios
nós conseguimos um número recorde de
atendimento na educação
infantil e pulou do zero em 2012
há 90% de garantia de vagas para
crianças de zero a seis anos sem a
necessidade de ajuizamento de nenhuma
ação judicial apenas com soluções
negociadas com soluções de transação e
com a busca dos gestores públicos ao
lado horizontalmente como parceiros e
como integrantes de um processo na
construção de uma solução conjunta ea
maior ruptura que nós podemos ter e a
maior resistência que encontramos entre
muitos de nós aplicadores do direito é a
noção de que a autoridade o respeito ea
própria punição quando necessária ela
fica mitigada se não for feita com o
autoritarismo com o formalismo exagerado
e desnecessário das regras jurídicas
essa é uma é o maior obstáculo que nós
ao trazer a idéia de uma nova cara da
justiça onde a humanização e o estado
doado é muito mais do que simplesmente
aplicar a lei
essa é a maior resistência que nós temos
então ouso dizer que para que busquemos
hoje uma nova justiça onde o problema
onde a lei e onde finalmente a aplicação
das leis com a busca de uma nova
consciência social de uma nova
urbanização pode buscar fazer senão a
solução perfeita mas uma solução efetiva
para os problemas que nós estamos
acostumados a vivenciada
quem busca justiça e é isso que nós
vemos todos os dias
não precisa e não quer uma justiça
acaica uma justiça extremamente formal
uma justiça que no afã de garantir
direito trabalha para si o poder eo
autoritarismo através da punição e do
medo
não acredito que nós nesse universo em
expansão
nesse novo modo de se ver as pessoas às
suas profissões os seus dons possamos
pensar em robotizado à justiça quando na
verdade o que se busca é dar aquele que
nos legítima a nós funcionários públicos
juízes promotores o verdadeiro poder de
garantia de seus direitos e é nisso que
eu acredito no poder da sociedade no
poder da mobilização social no poder de
cada um de vocês de cada um de nós
enquanto cidadãos
quando nós não só pelo voto mas quando
cada um de nós
ao se colocado publicamente perante uma
solução de conflitos talvez de modo mais
instigante e dizendo onde e como
gostaria que a solução fosse pelo menos
alcançada pela justiça pudesse vir e
participar da efetiva resolução dos
conflitos
acredito sim e ainda continua ainda
contínuo depois de mais de 20 anos
acreditando que nós podemos mudar o
mundo
sou ainda aquela promotora jovem não tão
jovem assim e talvez só muito hoje
talvez hoje muito mais nervosa do que
estava naquele dia
mas o poder que cada um de nós como
pessoas como o sociedade tem e nos hino
certamente nos repassa em cada
atendimento em cada pedido de auxílio em
cada reunião audiência é este judicial e
que chega promotoria como um grito como
uma um pedido de socorro aqueles que
mais necessitam é o que me move a
levantar todos os dias a acreditar que
ainda podemos nesse nosso universo
humanizado aquilo que está a grandes e
longos passos de ser uma justiça com a
qual sonhamos
por isso esse universo em expansão
ao contrário do que muitos pensam onde a
fórmula que deveria ser mágica e poderia
nos robotizado ouço dizer vem e deve nos
fazer como uma uma justiça rápida ágil e
efetiva
buscando sempre o coração ea humanização
de cada uma das pessoas que nos música
que busca justiça nas suas principais
causas nas suas dos seus principais e
mais dolorosas conflitos
isso é uma utopia como disse galeano que
ela sirva para nós cada vez avançar os
mais tem um ótimo dia de trabalho
[Aplausos]
[Música]